well we have finally arrived at the
central issue of Jungian dream
interpretation I know from the e-mails I
have received from listeners that many
of your questions revolve around how to
interpret their dreams or what a
particular dream means this area is
quite complicated but with the ideas you
have from the first six episodes you
should be able to make some headway
through this fascinating area of dreams
I like to say to my analytical patients
that you need to interpret at least 30
or so of your own dreams before you feel
confident in the process like everything
else in life there is a learning curve
so just stick with it if you run into
difficulties just email me and I may be
able to point you in the right direction
at this stage focus on your own dream
interpretation and leave the dreams of
friends aside until you feel competent
in this process there are a few things I
need you to bear in mind as we work
through this area together the first is
that the dreamer owns the dream this
means that whatever the interpretation
is unless the dreamer feels that the
interpretation is accurate
interpretation is wrong the second issue
is that dreams of vibrant vital aspects
of the psyche so need to be treated with
great care and respect never ever over
interpret a dream always work through
the dream to the point that there is
still some life and juice left in it
thrashing a dream to death is a common
mistake we all make when we start
I like having dreams that occasionally I
cannot understand they usually make
sense later on in the week or month the
third issue that we need to be aware of
is not to take the message that the
dream offers as literal I can recall
that so often people
face a big decision in their lives and
say that they will wait until a dream
comes up and tells them what to do
dreams don't tell you what to do they
give you a comment on the conscious
attitude you hold at the end of the day
it is the relationship between your
dream material and the ego that really
counts so these three points again are
one the interpretation has to fit the
dreamer to don't thrash the dream and
three the dream offers a comment not a
prescription our work on dream
interpretation will cover at least three
podcasts more likely more as we have a
great deal of material to cover in
today's episode we need to deal with the
issue of sleep and why we should
interpret dreams at all
we spend about a third of our life
asleep yet it is an area of our
existence we know very little about it
is during sleep that we dream so let's
focus on certain of the core essentials
to this wonderful encounter with
Morpheus who is the god of Dreams in
Greek mythology and the son of the god
of sleep hypnose not of course to be
confused with Morpheus in the movie
matrix although if you think about that
role that Morpheus had in the movie
his name is highly appropriate just as
an aside if anyone is interested in the
movie matrix let me know via email as I
would be very interested in discussing
this issue from a union perspective so
back to the topic of sleep there are two
physiological states of sleep that we
all go through each night these are non
REM or non-rapid eye movement and REM or
rapid eye movement so the term REM REM
is an acronym for the phrase rapid eye
movement because when we are in REM our
eyes move rapidly while we are as
sleeeeep if ever you have watched
someone having an intense dream you can
often notice that their eyes are
flickering back and forth under their
eyelids so non REM or n REM is a
physiological state of sleep in which
there is no REM or no rapid eye movement
non REM is the start of a sleep cycle
and the phase of non REM usually lasts
for the first 90 minutes of sleep what
is very important to know about the
state of sleep is that our overall
physiological functions are reduced this
means that our heart rate our
respiration and blood pressure are
reduced this is also the time when we
can have small episodic muscle movements
such as small twitches in the body deep
a stage non REM that is stages 3 & 4
have us so reduced in responses that if
we are awoken during these stages we
often appear quite disoriented and may
take quite a while to come to full
consciousness if we are awakened by
night terrors a specific kind of dream
activity and sleep disturbance we take
quite a while to come back to focus we
may not be quite sure if we are awake or
not and often the scary parts of the
dream still seem to be very real you
have all experienced a night terror at
some stage and it is quite different to
a nightmare when we awake from a
nightmare we know we are in our beds and
it was just a bad dream but in a night
terror that takes quite a while to clear
we need non-rem to allow the body to do
its repair functions REM phase sleep on
the other hand is quite different to non
REM in REM another set of physiological
behaviors occur that market is quite
different from non REM our heart rate
respiration rate and blood pressure are
all
elevated in fact in some people these
functions are higher than if they were
awake another peculiar behavior occurs
in REM that is our thermoregulation is
altered thermoregulation refers to the
body's automatic capacity to raise or
lower its core temperature based on the
environmental temperature we all know
that if we go outside in winter without
enough warm clothing that we start to
shiver if it is the height of summer we
often start to sweat in rem something
different occurs and that is we start to
use a thermoregulation function called
poi kilo thermic regulation p o i ki l o
th ER m IC regulation which means that
our body temperature varies with the
environmental temperature as the bedroom
gets cooler so does the body and
vice-versa so we stop shivering or
sweating do you remember those nights
where you suddenly woke up from an
intense dream and you were freezing cold
and started shivering or you were so hot
that you started sweating well part of
that is because you were in rem and the
body was engaged in pokey low thermic
temperature regulation a very important
behavior occurs in rem and that is our
skeletal muscles are paralyzed this
means that the muscles we use to walk or
to lift things like the muscles and the
legs or the arms no longer function why
is that do you think the simple answer
is that during REM sleep
we are often moving in our dreams say
running from a pack of wolves or trying
to catch someone if our skeletal muscles
were still active we would thrash about
in bed and injure ourselves or our
partners we also know that when we are
very young we
spend about half of our sleeping life in
rem in other words active dreaming as we
get older this amount of REM diminishes
so by the time we get to adulthood we
spend about 25% of our sleep in rem this
proportion also diminishes as we get
into our senior years now there is a
definite cycle between non REM and REM
during our sleep we start with non REM
in stage 1 of non REM we are in a
transitional state and are easily awoken
in stage 2 we feel a greater sense of
relaxation and are in light sleep in
stages 3 & 4 we're in deep sleep and
this is the time that the body engages
in restorative functions now you we can
also dream in non REM but these dreams
are far less powerful than their REM
cousins the first REM phase follows non
REM stage 4 so we have to go through non
REM to finally get to the good stuff
in rim
the cycle of sleep goes from non-rem one
to two to three to four and sometimes
back up to non-rem three then two then
into REM the critical issue is that if
you are in REM and are awoken you have
to get back to REM by going through non
REM phases first which means that if we
are awoken in a dream or we are awoken
because of a nightmare
when we go back to sleep we don't
actually go straight back into the dream
we have to go through some non REM
phases first we also know that if you
prevent someone from having adequate REM
sleep two very important consequences
result the first is that the person
progressively becomes more and more
agitated and less capable so their
cognitive capacities are reduced they
will have impairment in their fine motor
skills first so that they find it hard
to do something like put a key into a
lock or to write something down then
their gross motor skills are impaired so
that they act as though they are very
clumsy or even look drunk but the second
issue is far more dangerous and that is
if you deprive someone of REM phase
sleep long enough often two or three
days they begin to have disturbances in
their reality testing and executive
functioning in severe situations you
will note that a REM deprived person may
actually have brief breakdowns in their
reality testing so that they may begin
to even hallucinate this is why a
classic form of punishment or torture
that all nations have practiced since
early times is simply to keep the
prisoner awake in other words to
severely REM deprive the prisoner those
of you that have worked very long shifts
will know that REM deprivation feels
really really unpleasant
you feel as though you're walking in
molasses you can't make sense of basic
issues you forget things but most of all
you feel like you're prepared to sleep
at any cost